[musique]
ok déjà des secrets de plus en plus effrayants
bien sûr pour ceux qui sont là
[musique]
et ici il portait aussi un gros chapelet synchrone
Je serais heureux de l'enlever de quel côté de la route
machines frotter lunettes vie recoudre treba
oublier le besoin
[musique]
les fans qui éclatent veulent juste partir
dans le lait de tout départ et pendant des siècles [ __ ]
mères
personne n'a forgé d'herbes avec Intel c'était
service assis inscrit au premier sheva
ongles cassés
prises ici par couleur et année de raisin
donné pour donner une riche couronne et eux-mêmes
grand inventaire raisins et son
caractéristiques analyse chimique et mine
Fils était-ce toute l'armée sur laquelle tu étais
la mienne sera et la maison sera ses propres cendres
poudre à canon pendant longtemps vous êtes prêt
rêve
intact
[musique]